avec julien chez ida bonjour julien
bonjour pauline et c'est l'information
principale de cette matinée elon musk le
milliardaire propriétaire fondateur de
tesla et space x a réussi son opa sur
twitter effectivement l'homme le plus
riche du monde se paye l'un des plus
importants réseaux sociaux de la planète
pour 44 milliards de dollars titre d
independence à 50 ans le
multimilliardaire contrôle désormais
trois des plus grosses entreprises du
monde
et comment la presse internationale à l
île ce rachat est bien du mal un général
est assez mitigé voire circonspecte
voire très critique à l'égard des lots
de masques qui selon ses propres
employés
2t cela aurait un management de très
autoritaire mais ce rachat pause avant
tout une question éthique acte
désintéressé ou délire égocentrique
titre la frankfurter allgemeine zeitung
pardon
le milliardaire connu aussi pour
utiliser très régulièrement twitter n'a
jamais fait dans la dentelle lorsqu'il
s'agissait de donner sa propre opinion
notamment lorsqu il l'insultait
publiquement joe biden ou encore
lorsqu'il comparaît justin trudeau à
adolf hitler voilà et c'est justement
cela qui cela qui inquiète le new york
times car dire qu'on veut faire de
twitter une forteresse de la liberté
d'expression c'est bien joli écrit le
quotidien mais cela dépend de la
définition qu'on se donne de cette
liberté d'expression et pour faire
simple pour elle mais ce que celle ci ne
doit pas avoir de limites avec le risque
rappelle le quotidien de voir abondé des
propos sexistes à l'égard des femmes des
propos racistes voire insultants à
l'égard des minorités le journal prédit
un avenir sombre pour twitter qui
pourrait selon elon musk devenir un
endroit effrayant on va parler de la
politique en france à présent et après
la victoire d'emmanuel macro la presse
s'interroge évidemment c'est normal sur
les jours d'après lui avec un emmanuel
macron certes vainqueur de cette
présidentielle mais une victoire due en
partie au refus de laisser d'extrême
droite entrée à l'élysée beaucoup de
questions une de la presse française on
voit 6,2 à gauche libération c'est de
l'or du changement c'est pour quand et à
droite l'humanité macron entends-tu pour
ces deux quotidiens classé à gauche le
message est clair emmanuel macron ne
doit surtout pas oublier que il est
entré de nouveau à l'elysée grâce aux
voix de toutes les formations politiques
notamment à celles de la gauche
libération parle d'une zone grise après
une victoire qui a soulagé une majorité
de l'électorat français et en même temps
avec l'inquiétude d'une partie de cette
majorité de voir le président à nouveau
exercer le pouvoir de manière
autoritaire le futur quinquennat écrit
l'éditorialiste devait être plus
collectif et forcément mieux auquel cas
les cinq ans à venir seraient je cite
intenable en parler de zones grises un
instant pauline et bien le figaro parle
plutôt d'un tourment en français que
dire d'un pays où le président réélu
prononce le soir de sa victoire l'un des
discours les plus creux je cite de sa
vie politique et en même temps un soir
où la perdante elle parle de victoire
éclatante c'est ce que se demande le
journal qui parle d'un chantier
herculéen qui attend emmanuel macron
c'est dans ce contexte d'instabilité
politique que va démarrer la campagne
des législatives
oui la campagne officielle n'a pas
encore commencé loin de là mais elle est
déjà dans tous les esprits depuis
dimanche soir 20h01 trois blocs se
disputeront la majorité explique le
lendemain le jour le parti présidentiel
en marche le rassemblement national et
les insoumis de jean luc mélenchon qui
se rêve à matignon sa grande bataille
électorale aura lieu dans deux mois mais
ce sera durant cette part de l'occasion
de voir le jeu des alliances entre les
différentes formations politiques
notamment de voir si la gauche arrivera
enfin à s'unir comme l'écrit le journal
l'a pas réussi à la faire avant la
présidentielle peut être le fera t-elle
durant les deux mois c'est toute la
question est ce qu'on peut imaginer
emmanuel macron gouverner sans la
majorité à l'assemblée nationale eh bien
il selon l'opinion dans un pays aussi
fragmentée tout reste possible il est
impossible de prévoir ce qui se passera
dans deux mois plusieurs formations
politiques ont déjà décrite ces
législatives comme un éventuel 3e tour
de la présidentielle tant les divisions
sont profondes en france la majorité
sortante cherchera à rassembler écrit le
quotidien libéral mais dans le même
temps les extrêmes pourraient de leur
côté dominé dominer la vie parlementaire
du pays de quoi faire dire à brigitte
macron avec une pointe d'humour à
emmanuel macron s'il fallait préparer la
chambre d'amis en vue vous l'aurez
compris d'une hypothétique cohabitation
l étranger le chancelier allemand olaf
scholz est sous le feu des critiques à
cause des hésitations sur l'aide
accordée par berlin à l'ukraine oui vous
le rappeliez à l'instant ces critiques
interviennent à un moment où le ministre
russe des affaires des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov met en garde
contre un danger réel de troisième
guerre mondiale alors réelle menace ou
simple propagande on ne sait pas on ne
sait pas vraiment le diplomate faisait
partie avait effectivement il faisait
part à ce moment de sa fatigue disait-il
suite aux échecs de négociation pour
trouver une trêve entre l'ukraine et la
russie dans ce contexte c'est le
gouvernement allemand qui est ciblé par
la presse allemande pour ses hésitations
notamment à livrer des armes lourdes à
l'ukraine comme on fait les états unis
récemment berlin est façonnée par la
peur titre le suddeutsche zeitung
peur de quoi et bien que ces armes ne
tombent entre de mauvaises mains mais
aussi peur de voir l'allemagne
s'embarquer dans une guerre dont elle ne
veut pas écrit die welt mais en voulant
garder l'allemagne hors d'une guerre est
bien berlin soutient indirectement selon
le journal les régimes autoritaires
comme celui de la russie c'est d'autant
plus dangereux écrit le quotidien
lorsque vous avez en face de vous un
état doté de l'armé nucléaire merci
julien pour cette revue de presse